so does anybody have a desire to look at
any one of these exercises or a solution
for any one of them let me just Thursday
afternoon it's late so it's so let me
and let me just look at the second one
just because it's very elementary and
maybe easy to dodge yes so we want to
show that we want to show that so if we
let M K is the number of K matchings you
know in the graph if we just want to
show that the these coefficients are for
the matching polynomial a log concave so
you want to show that
this this quality this inequality and in
fact this is true with something to
spare as we've seen already earlier that
you can put you know ratio binomial
coefficients here but let's just do so
this is a complete it's an elementary
proof it doesn't require any any
knowledge of roots or anything
stability properties anything like that
and arises from the Markov chain
analysis of a matchings so so what we we
want to do is look at the look at the
two sets and we kind of want to set up
an injective mapping from from this this
set of pairs to the set of pairs or
actually what we'll do is a multivalued
mapping where the out degree from here
is strictly larger than the in degree
over here okay multivalued nothing so
the idea is that you you look at the
structure does anybody you wondered
never go at this no it's a grow it's a
bipartite graph so so it's going to be a
these are going that this is going to be
the the set of these pairs this is going
to be the set of these pairs and we're
gonna we're going to set up a graph so
actually we're going to partition these
percentage chunks same chunks over here
and it'll it'll be the case that between
each corresponding pair of chunks the
out degree from here is strictly larger
than the in degree here yeah right good
so that's basically it right I'll give
you the benefit so so yeah so you got a
if you take a pair of a k plus one
matching a K minus one matching indeed
when you look at the Union you get a
bunch of alternating paths and you know
so that you know that sometimes though
they may they may include cycles yeah
that's that's an alternate a trivial
alternating path so so if we if we if we
call these right so let's let's call a
path let me let me suppose this this
this corresponds to blue and this
corresponds to red right dotted and
dashed like so the so so call an
alternating path is blue if both its
endpoints are blue both are both its end
edges are blue right so this is a blue
path right because it has its odd length
and it has one more blue edge than red
edge right and call an alternating path
red otherwise right
if we have if we have if the blue
matching is an MK plus is a k plus one
matching and the red matching is 2 K
minus one matching we must have two more
red paths than blue pausing
sorry which way round did I say well let
me say two more blue than red really
doesn't matter
teal and blue than red in other words
when we put the two met
matching scale let me redraw this
picture there must be you know two more
pars like that like this they just by
Counting
of course the navy or what kind maybe
you know a great number of both types
but ultimately must be two more of these
so I'm gonna partition the side into
according to how many red and blue parts
they have so so this part of the
partition let me call it you know ER or
something this is this is this has R
plus one blue paths and our minus 1 red
bars now I do I guess you maybe we're
suggesting so I what I'm going to do to
map this any given pair here I'm going
to pick any any blue path and I'm going
to flip it flip its edges from red to
blue and blue to red so that'll take me
from that'll take me from something here
to something here where there are our
blue and our red right so the the out
degree here is our plus one because I
got our plus one through parts to choose
but the in degree over here is only our
because to go to go back I just have to
I have to flip a blue path back accurate
and so so this this gives me the desired
inequality and in fact it immediately
gives me a at least a ke a K over k plus
one factor because because I get the
ratio of R plus 1 to it and so slightly
open exercise is whether you can also
get the other factor you need which is
of M plus K minus 1 over n plus K where
n is the total number of edges in the
graph
so you can do it without referring to
roots yeah this is this is nothing to do
oh that's my that's my question for this
evening when you go home right so
whether you whether you can put the
whether you can get by this very
elementary arguing where you can get the
binomial coefficients in there okay yes
[Music]
you're referring to the coefficients
that I wrote up before but I did and
even I did yet another transformation no
but I did I did I was talking earlier
about the high temperature expansion so
the coefficients of the high temperature
expansion have this log concavity
property I don't know but I'm I don't
much
you can make them on the light they
might be real and because it's square I
think they really okay for the high
temperature expansion so this is the
transformation it's an even polynomial
only yeah you can also exactly just a
generalization this so the general
question about whether you know one can
what kind of relationship there is
between this is a very tenuous
relationship between Markov chain when
the core of analysis and low concavity
properties and therefore stability
properties so I don't haven't really
more to say about it but that's hmm
possibly something we can look at this
semester okay I mean you know in the
interest of time and it unless anybody
has a burning desire to talk about one
of these others I'm going to leave them
for the moment and then if anyone wants
to ask me about it them including the
ones on the back which are a little more
involved then I'd be happy to answer
those let me move on then and I should
say by the way you know I got some
questions in the break so this this
transformation using the high
temperature expansion it's not supposed
to be obvious right I mean I inspect
anybody to believe this without you know
fair amount of work and in fact it's
it's it's number five on the on the
exercise sheet to verify that this is
true and it's a it's a kind of an
inclusion exclusion argument and so
certainly it wasn't meant that was not
this transformation from spin
configurations to high temperature
graphs is not supposed to be obvious
because it's also used actually in that
first part of the tour guys talking
about how to prove the existence of a
phase transition for the easing model is
the high temperature expansions actually
used in order to analyze what happens at
high temperatures so the fact that the
magnetization that the origin goes to
zero so it's used in that context mmm
high to high temperature meaning low B
and it's a small value of the
interaction converges
and doesn't flow
okay so that's all right so the rest of
what I want to say is about how to use
other methods so we do have this
randomized algorithm that allows you to
it gets a good approximation to the
easing model partition function for
ferromagnetic using model at all values
of the parameters and and all graphs so
that's a pretty that's pretty strong
Jean and you know can we do something
using other methods to really make that
deterministic and so and the two methods
I remain as someone talk about are
related to the two characterizations of
phase transitions that that we talked
about earlier so so first of all let's
talk about correlation okay so it's so
this is such a game what we expect is
that the computationally the problem
should be easier when there's no phase
transition so no phase transition and
probabilistic sense means that as the
boundary goes to infinity it has no
effect on the origin in other words
correlations between different spins
should decay with distance okay so we
want to use that in order to get
algorithms at least for some values of
the parameters where we have a no phase
transition now there's a so there's a
beautiful technique do to draw bytes
which sort of solves a result it handles
this problem for using model and indeed
for general to spin systems at least
gives you it gives you a path general to
spin system so what we're going to look
at is so the easing model on bounded
degree graphs now
that's so they're the all the degrees
are going to be less than or equal to
Delta and for simplicity okay so let's
say we're good we're going to look at
zero field so we're going to look at
lambda equals one which is means there's
no there's no bias between zero and
between a plus spin and - spit and so
the remarkable fact here is that so so
for any any graph of maximum degree for
all beta greater than so it's a leader
between 1 and critical temperature
critical beta there exists a polynomial
time I called it an F Peters right so
and fully polynomial time approximation
scheme for the easy model partition
function services
and equals one hmm okay so so what's
this critical value so this is this is
the critical value so where the phase
transition happens for infinite D
regular trees a for the Delta Regulatory
so this is the critical point or
infinite Delta regular trees and it's
equal to Delta minus two over Delta so
so so magnetic regime there's this beta
critical and we're talking about beavers
in this regime where we have well we
have no phase transition phase
transition down here no phase transition
up so wherever there's no phase just so
it goes all the way up to the point
where the phase transition starts we
have another deterministic algorithm and
so so notice what what we're doing is
we're relating the computation of this
of this partition function to a phase
transition not on on on trees of the
same degree so in other words we're
saying that the worst case in a sense
for this problem is trees went reached
when the problem starts getting tricky
for trees we get when correlations are
no longer decay on trees that's exactly
the point where we're we can't handle
general graphs either well they're still
on the tree there's still a phase
transition so when when you're when
you're
[Music]
on the other side of this you have a
critical field okay that'll be a phase
transition in the field okay and you
can't yeah so this hot there's a I'll
say a little bit more about that later
but okay so alright so so how do how
does the veidt's algorithm work so so
there are two steps first of all you you
you trans transform your graph G into a
tree and then secondly you perform a
computation on the tree and you use the
phase you use the the lack of phase
transition to argue that the the the
that computation the computation on what
could be an infant could be an
exponentially large tree can actually be
truncated at a small depth and therefore
computation is feasible okay so so now
that this tree is is something that we
already saw in Nikhil's one of the kills
talks to the self avoiding walk tree so
so I believe this is even the same graph
that Nikhil used okay because these
things blow up put it pretty quickly if
you take something bigger so so the self
avoiding walk tree of this graph is
exactly what Nikhil [ __ ] I'll root it at
the vertex one you have to read it
somewhere so we'll read it at one and
then we just look at all the possible
self avoiding walks so once you've gone
from one to two you can then go to three
one two three you can go to either two
or four and once you've gone one to two
to three you can either go to four or
you can go back to one so here where
this is a special verdicts we're closing
a cycle and similarly here one two three
one two three two two you go back to one
and close the cycle and one two one two
three to four you that's a dead end
right so now the really clever thing
here is that whenever you close a cycle
you put a boundary condition into the
tree so so this will this will be a this
will be a - it doesn't greatly but
they're complementary so point is we
closed this cycle in two different ways
that the cycle one two three back to one
we've closed it in two different
directions either either by this walk
all by this walk and those two different
directions result in complimentary
boundary conditions at the closing
vertex based on a fixed ordering of the
descendants of one right okay so now so
the remarkable remarkable theorem is
that the the marginal
our V which is the probability in G that
Sigma V is plus
is exactly equal to the same marginal in
the tree so so so looking at the you
know marginal probability of this guy
being plus or minus and this is that
this this is exactly preserved when you
when you go to the tree with these care
features and boundary conditions because
we have no no field it will be a
half-year but not once we even if you
have boundary conditions on this tree
which will yeah in this graph okay so so
let's see so
and so now how do we compute it so
itself since this is a tree it's pretty
easy to compute recursively the marginal
at the root so the marginal that the
root will be it'll be this if we have
the root vertex V and a bunch of
children in the tree DD by the way I'm
just using as a D is Delta minus 1 so
it's the Delta regular tree has arity
it's a diri tree where D is Delta where
this one so to compute the marginal at V
it's just the ratio of the partition
function when I put a plus here and
minus here and I can compute that since
these are these are independent sub
trees I can compute that from the same
marginals at the leaves at the roots of
those sub trees so so I'll get you know
this will be Z this is Z G Plus over zg-
which is since they're the sub trees are
independent it's the product of
so when when I put a plus it at the root
then I get a contribution so from each
each subtree I get a contribution of Zi
I plus which has no so then then I have
a plus here and a plus here so I have no
beta and I also in in the case where I
set this to be minus I get a beta from
the cut edge and then it's the opposite
way around on on the denominator and now
I can just divide through by Zi minus to
convert this into into the foot into the
form that I wanted okay
and so
[Music]
so heated there are two so for the
moment let me let me omit the proof that
the white streak instruction works it it
works actually for any two spin system
so not just for the easing one but for
any system with two spins because it
essentially involves a a telescoping a
telescoping product which works only for
random variables that are two valued so
let me now go to the second part which
is to argue that this recurrence
actually converges rapidly so that we
can cut off the computation and the tree
at a logarithmic depth okay and there
and thereby do the computation
exhaustively on the logarithmic depth
which is polynomial which is a
polynomial time computation okay so so
here's the we're analyzing this
recurrence
okay and so first thing I want to do is
change your variable R is going to I'll
write as that's alright s is s is equal
to log R and so now my occurrence
becomes this product turns into a into a
son
and so now I can I can use so and let me
call this G of s so I can use the mean
value theorem to - right - right
like this so certainly the the so this
is soup over so you know the the
gradient certainly bounds that the neck
of the biggest value of the gradient on
any given variable will bound the change
in the function okay around the relative
change in the function so what we're
going to show the main calculation is to
show that this thing is less than one so
this is less than less than or equal to
C which is less than 1 provided Beto's
in the desired range so beater beaters
the greater than beta critical greater
than beta critical which is Delta minus
2 over Delta and that'll mean that you
get a country okay so that'll mean that
the if you look at if you look at the
the
[Music]
as in two recurrences being carried out
on the tree the error between the error
the error at the at the parent node will
be strictly less than the maximum value
or in fact will be of one minus epsilon
times the error at the worst error at
any one of the children okay so we have
a contraction at every level of the tree
and so if I so therefore you know after
after death L if I start off the
recursion with two different initial
sets of initial values here and the
depth is L then the the error in these
two will be bounded by C to the L times
the whatever they were whatever the
initial it was imagine that one of these
is the perfect tree the the
exponentially sighs cell phone winning
war tree which gives me the exact values
and this is just my computation that
starts off at some arbitrary set of
initial values okay then then I ensure
that I get a a small error in in the
marginal at the root providing my depth
is larger so a depth L you'll get that
the we call that this this ratio the
exact one R and R prime my computational
one so this will be this will be less
than or equal to C to the L times they
times the maximum error here the maximum
error here so it seems that it could be
infinitely large because when you have a
plus or a minus boundary condition the
ratio is infinite or zero but this this
recurrence Maps you know infinity to 1
over beta and 0 to
and 0 to beta so in fact the I can
always assume that the worst value worst
error on my leaves is is beta to the D
or 1 over the beta to the D okay so mmm
this will be less than the max max max
error at leaves which is less than or
equal to C C to the L times log of 1
over beta to the D and so I take L to be
a gal to be order n over epsilon then I
am sorry log n over epsilon take L to be
order log n over epsilon then this then
this thing will be as small as n over
epsilon people see you down here
probably not that slightness across then
the error is less than or equal to n
over epsilon so far if I've got an n
over epsilon error in the logarithm that
translates to a 1 plus or minus 4 n over
epsilon a 4 epsilon over an error errors
epsilon over an answer for epsilon over
a net multiplicative error in R itself
and from that using recursion I can get
an estimate of the whole partition
function where there are about epsilon
and the running time will be so that the
the running time will be Delta to the L
because I'm cutting off my recursion at
depth L and this is a delta a graph of
bounded degree Delta so this will be
order this all set need be polynomial in
all right so I guess I need to do one
complete one computation which is this
one okay
but very importantly is an L infinity
military you know in order to depend on
a number of means which is also part of
this one yeah you can get stronger
results with different norms actually
you can play with these norms and get
aget for example you can get results
with bounded average degree of them
rather than bounded degree by playing
with the norm
right so
let's look at this guy so we just have
to we just have to sum the partial
derivatives of this function and if you
do that you get you get my word for it
you get and so we want to maximize this
and the minimum value of this is 2 so we
will get you know 1 plus B 2 squared on
the bottom cancel out a factor of 1 plus
B 2 and you get 1 minus B 2 over 1 plus
B 2 and then there's a D factor coming
from the summation so this will be less
than 1 provided provided D is less than
that sorry provided Vito is bigger than
D minus 1 over D plus 1 which is the
same as Delta minus T over Delta
so right so that that's the basis of a
bunch of correlation decay algorithms I
guess maybe I won't
I won't go back and do so so this the
proof of the veidt's there is elementary
and beautiful but I may come back to it
later I have a minute so right so you
remark so this this approach again it
works for all at least the translation
to the self avoiding walk tree works for
all to spin systems and in particular so
so in the anti ferromagnetic case it
still works same argument and the second
part also work so the second part but so
the second part is actually a little
delicate in fact because the second part
in general it would is really showing
that imagine the correlation decay on a
on a tree really just says okay so for
an arbitrary boundary put here the
effect the effect on the spinet the root
goes to zero as as this goes to infinity
but in the veidt's tree we actually got
these boundary conditions so in fact you
you you you not only need you not only
need this this decay of correlations to
hold with no boundary regions you
actually needed to hold for general
boundary conditions and in particular
the boundary conditions these pluses and
things can be very close to the root so
so getting this to work in general the
second step this decay analysis does
require you to I mean this it does work
in this in this simple case but if you
but in most in in in more elaborate
applications the fact that the decay of
correlations with no boundary conditions
actually holds also with boundary
conditions arbitrarily close to the root
of course the the boundary conditions
are the same in the two copies of the
tree right so that the two copies of the
tree you've got the same boundary
conditions close to the root it's only
the stuff far away that changes but
these things do have the potential to
mess you up in general and this is this
is a question as to whether you know
some weak spatial mixing is the jargon
for correlations decaying in the absence
of any boundary conditions and strong
spatial mixing is the stronger property
where you have work where it where it
also occurs even with boundary
conditions it's close to the root and so
it turns out that when you're applying
veidt's so you can always in a two spin
system you can always go over to to this
tree formulation but your argument for
decay of correlations may fail if weak
spatial mixing does not imply strong
spatial mixing okay now it turns out
that for the anti ferromagnetic easing
model which is the thing I started to
draw here so for the anti ferromagnetic
easy model this argument works and it
even works with a field up to acrid up
to the critical field for decay of
correlations in weak sense and so for
the anti family easing model you have a
oh and then for the only fair amenities
in model you also have the fact that
okay so it's anti ferromagnetic easing
so you have on the one hand you have an
algorithm for D regular graphs for
bounded degree graphs or bounded degree
graphs
whenever the whenever the Gibbs measure
is unique even with a field unique on
the on the Delta regulatory Gibbs
measure on the Delta regulatory is
unique and in this case you also have a
complementary result that this is you
this is veidt's fly and some prove a
complimentary result that outside this
range of parameters the problem not only
does the algorithm know work the problem
becomes np-hard and B hardness Outsiders
in since
this regime in the sense that you can
find you can construct graphs bound the
degree Delta such that you can't you
prove you know it's np-hard to
approximate the partition function when
when the field and those beta and the
land are in the range of non-uniqueness
okay so now in the in the ferromagnetic
case we don't we in the ferromagnetic
case we can't hope for this because we
know from the Markov chain Monte Carlo
thing that we have polynomial time
algorithms everywhere on the other end
you can't get the veidt's thing to work
throughout the uniqueness regime with a
field in the in the ferromagnetic case
it's a bit of a mystery that but we
can't do that but in fact this this
property fails in the in the
ferromagnetic case and firming in any
case you can stick but you can stick
carefully chosen boundary conditions
close to the root such that you do not
get this decay of correlations property
even though you have unique ok so that
motivates a little bit the last so last
thing I want to talk about is is this
polynomial interpolation so now I'm
going to write so you're going to hear a
great deal more about this from Sasha
tomorrow so I'm just going to do one
exam example application keeping with
our theme of the easing model I'm just
going to show you how it works for the
easing model and then session
I'm sure talked about many other
examples tomorrow so
and the idea here is right so we've
we've already used we've already shown
how to use correlation decay which is
one notion of spin systems being well
behaved and not not having a phase
transition we use that to get algorithms
and indeed in some cases to show that it
represents a boundary of tractability so
the the idea now is to is to look at the
other characterization than zeroes of
the partition function and see if what
we can get out of that algorithmically
it's a lack of zero yeah so yeah if you
have strong spatial mixing then you do
actually have Markov I mean you can that
actually implies that mark northern
every graph the graph has to be what's
called amenable so Amin Amin z-- that
size of a boundary of a set is small
compared to its interior so like
lattices and things
obviously they don't go beyond what you
can do with correlation decay because
correlation K get gets you everything
you could hope for in that case well
amenable graphs yes but not on yeah
right okay polynomial interpolation okay
so what we want to do is write so so
very simple setting for this here
because we have the liang theorem right
so so what's what's our goal is goal is
going to be your compute partition
function the ferromagnetic using using
partition function approximately of
course which you know be writing zg so
this is in the liang parameterization
for all and this is going to work for
all lambda not equal to 1 so as we know
the 0 is lie on the unit disk so in this
setting
zero this is the unit disk and we know
that there are no zeros inside the disk
and what we want to do is compute this
thing at any point in the disk that's
you know in this in the strict interior
and the beautiful but simple idea is
just that so so yeah and those zeros in
here then the Taylor series of set so so
Taylor series of logs II will converge
in here and indeed you don't need to
turns out you don't need to take very
many terms of it in order to get a good
approximation to this point so you say
you're going to you're going to
essentially use it as a means of
bootstrapping the value at zero which is
a an easy point so z0 is a infinite
field right so that so that's case where
you know basically everything it's plus
or everything is - that's it's equal to
one in fact when lambda equals zero
bootstrap the known value of the
polynomial at zero to any point inside
the disk using the using the truncated
Taylor series and so the the fact from a
very special case of the general
theorems of just you okay
I'm it raised there oh okay
so that if we if we so we take a order
order Lord
with a log n ur epsilon terms of the
Taylor series around zero will give a a
plus or minus epsilon approximation of
log Z where n here is the degree of the
polynomial and Epps ya epsilon is the
desired error so this is the degree of
the polynomial which in our case is just
n the size of the graph
okay then may or may not spell that out
but I'm assuming you'll probably do this
so so and once again so a plus or minus
epsilon approximation of log Z will give
us a 1 plus or minus multiplicative
approximation of Z itself right when
epsilon is small and so this is enough
okay and so so so the algorithm is then
very simple you just you take the Taylor
series you truncate it at this many
steps yeah there's many terms and spit
out the without the approximation no so
there's but there's some issues now so
so well there's an easy point so how do
you get the how do you compute that the
Taylor series of log Z well you can you
can compute it to compare the for the
its terms from the Taylor's from the
polynomial Z itself right using the
the case derivative of Z is related to
the derivative of its logarithm by by
triangular system and so you can to get
the terms of the Taylor series of log
these things you can dig them out from
the from the derivatives of Z and this
is all the valuators at zero evaluating
the jace any derivative of Z at zero is
just basically looking at its J's
coefficient okay so so so you so getting
the getting the terms of the Taylor
series is easy
Genesis log Z is easy now the bigger
issue computationally is that so how
long does it take to evaluate all of
these and so basically we're having to
evaluate the first log n coefficients of
the of the polynomial okay
and that vector that could be bad
because those involve all all cuts of
size
first n coefficients involve evolve cuts
of size where is that where there's the
most n vertices on one side of the cut
and so naively computing those
coefficients will require you know order
order n to the M time because they're at
the rent would by exhaustive enumeration
or end to the end of them just the
number of you know subsets of size M
from from our virtus vertex set now I
think you know and we have we have to
take n it has to be about log n so this
is n to the log n right this is what we
call quasi-polynomial so of course if
you're a mathematician like specially in
fact and in fact absolutely credit you
you you believe that this is this is
just fine and in fact it's a computer
scientist yeah a computer scientist
would much prefer to have an end to the
100 algorithm rather than an end to the
an end to the naught point a game and
since I can be designed as I'm gonna
shoot for this from ok but indulge
indulge me just okay and you know I mean
they're all kinds of arguments about how
this involves additional structure and
understanding and so on so in this case
yes so so what so beautiful idea of I
guess goose Rex and Patel and shows us
how to restructure this computation so
that you only in fact need to look at
cuts essentially in which in which s is
connected
if s has to be connected than the number
of cuts of size M isn't is no longer
enough in a bounded degree graph is no
longer you know n to the N that's my
it's Delta to the N it's like end times
Delta is the end because you just use if
this is if this has to be a connected
subgraph then you can just grow grow it
grow it with Delta choices at every step
so so how do you do that transformation
I'll just sketch out this is original
idea there's a there's a nice recent
paper of Helmut Perkins and rates that
does this same trick and gets more
general arguably more general setting
using using the cluster expansion which
is a tool from statistical physics that
is a general way of getting from
unconnect or disconnected arbitrary sub
graphs to connected ones so that's
something that's very nice and they've
applied in other settings as well so so
let's see so right so forth let's let's
right that's right z AZ that's right z
AZ so let's suppose the roots of Z are
r1 through RN so I can write Z since
it's constant term is 1 I can write it
like this
and
I can further write it okay so this is
the K elementary symmetric polynomial
evaluated at some of the roots they're
just expanding this thing out in the
obvious way
mm-hmm so so then okay so so these these
eks I mean that this is after all just
the original polynomial easy K's are
basically just signed coefficients of
the original polynomial so these e KS
themselves are sums over over cuts okay
so the UK
we can write them as you know some over
cuts of some some wait so so now the
idea is to use Newton's identities to
relate relate the the the e ke to the
power sums of the roots okay so so I
define PPT to be the
teeth power some of the roots then then
I get from Newton's identity again guess
what a form one form that I think was
mentioned in Young's lectures so
so this relates the power sums to the
ease now the nice thing about the power
sums is that they are they satisfy an
additive 'ti property so
in the sense that if you look at so if
you look at the partition function for
two disjoint graphs it's the product of
the partition functions so the roots are
just the union of the sets of roots and
so these power sums just okay and then
there's a sort of general theory of
graph invariants and the representation
as weighted sums over sub graphs tells
you that that so so this is I believe
due to Marian Frankel correct yeah tells
you that so a laugh in there in two and
represented in this way is so so F G is
additive in the sense if and only if it
is supported only on connected subgraph
you know I'm gonna say that you know you
have to get the exact definition of you
know the set of graphs and and how the
you know you have to account for the cut
edges correctly and so on and but
basically this is carries over and so
this is this is great because it tells
us that it tells us that these things
can be computed just by looking at just
by just as sums over connected sub
graphs and then you can use dynamic
programming to to compute to the e cage
which is what you want okay from from
from these identities so so since
there's only over connected summarize we
only got a polynomial size support that
we have to evaluate so for do each
coefficient each each s kind of you got
you've got to find the coefficient alpha
s of each s connected s they're only
holiday many many of them for each one
you can read it off by dynamic
programming from you know a combination
of you know these things that are
already commissions are already computed
and these things which just come from
the polynomial itself so in polynomial
time you can actually read off the
entire you know all the coefficients of
the original polynomial up to
logarithmic up to logarithmic depth okay
so the bottom line from all of this is
you get a you get a you've got a 1 plus
or minus epsilon approximation right to
to Z and sorry 2 to get to Z the lambda
for all well yeah for all lambda off the
unit circle and and this you get this in
time that's polynomial in polynomial in
well okay let me write it like this it's
it's polynomial in and a rep salon and
the dependence on the degree and on
lambda is is this so she got the degree
and the distance to the knee over to the
roots in in your exponent so of course
this is going to explode when you
approach the circle and of course it
explodes not quite so badly when the
degree of the graph goes up okay so I
guess I'm gonna when am I supposed to
finish okay yeah yeah okay so I I was
going to talk a bit about let me move
that to the open front so I I guess so
I'm not going to do any more kind of
Amit main some of the other any
questions at this point or should i what
I'd like to do is mention a few open
problems and then invite people in the
audience many of whom know a lot more
about some aspects of this to propose
any additional open problems so
okay
sir
right so I mean yeah very very obvious
but probably not easy open problems you
know so want a deterministic
deterministic approximation algorithm
giving a 1 plus or minus epsilon
approximation polynomial time for or you
know all values in the ferromagnetic
range of beta and and and and that at
the at the bad value of lambda so it's
so as we get to 0 field so there's no
reason at all to expect that this
wouldn't be possible but but we we don't
know how to do this ok and the Markov
chain Monte Carlo method does work so we
have a randomized algorithm for this but
not a deterministic one oh I see yeah
the Markov chain doesn't work at all for
coming face time absolutely yeah sorry
block of chain oh you mean this is even
this is interesting
sure yeah
so this interpolation approach works in
the full range of their the
interpolation approach it works in the
full range of beta yes doesn't it
doesn't see a problem with yep
and all degrees we also wanted want
don't want to bow non-degree right now
so so more Jeannette more generically
right both both correlation decay and of
polynomial interpolation suffer from the
problem that the the degree and the and
the distance to the roots or in the case
of correlation to kill you the distance
to the phase transition show up in the
exponent and it would be very nice if we
could prevent that so even even if even
if the running time I grow with them
maybe we can improve that dependence so
I so improve proved dependence on on
Delta and distance to distance to
criticality in both in all these
deterministic algorithms right so in
both correlation decay and elation and
this is not just the easing model but in
general so this is a general feature of
these methods that sting show up here
and there's a fundamental question
whether that can be improved I should
say you know so so in the case of the
easing model gives our running example
again you know we can we can do this
interpolation anywhere inside the unit
circle and you what you'd like to do it
at the point lambda equals one in
particular on the real line but you know
as the graph gets bigger the you can you
can even show that the the zeros the
positions of zeros actually get
arbitrarily close to this real point so
you can't so if you'd like I mean you
know you don't really need a disk I mean
you you can and I'm sure session I'll
talk about this tomorrow you can thread
sort of as long as you've got to sort of
abounded with strip here you can thread
it
to this point and still make the method
work but you're not gonna be able to do
that because these distances get
arbitrarily small as the graph gets much
oh wait you might be able to do it but
we don't currently know how to believe
that as as as you get larger larger
graphs the zeroes become denser no we
don't because we don't have a Liang
theorem there we don't know where the
zeroes are you can do something right so
so Sasha is going to tell you about lots
of so here my MS has been very much on
getting right to the phase transition
because that was directed but but yeah I
mean there are definitely non-trivial
ranges for all kinds of problems where
you can make that method work just just
not all the way in okay right so then so
again continuing with the easing model
so the Fisher zeros so we've looked
looked a lot at the Li yang zeroes
that's that they lie on the unit circle
that's the parameterization of the
polynomial in terms of lambda if you in
flip it around and look at the
parameterization in terms of beta then
you get a different on a little
different bunch of zeros a zero is in
beta and these are called Fisher zeros
so that's when you look at Z G lambda as
a polynomial and beta and these are
these are much less well understood than
the Li yang zeroes I mean they don't you
can't say a huge amount about them yet
although there's a lot of work going on
in general in locating zero
of partition functions so you know this
is so what we would like to do is is you
know get you know get it get a full
picture of where they lie and I can tell
you so so one thing that you can show
and a couple of things you can show is
that all right so hmm so here we're
looking at zeros and beta so remember we
have these critical complimentary
critical points for the ferromagnetic
and the anti ferromagnetic using model
and so this is the right this is this is
the regime where there's where there's
uniqueness of the Gibbs measure and you
can show that well one thing that Ashley
showed was that there's a circle around
one in which there are no zeros no
fishes zeros and another thing you can
show is that essentially there's a
there's a strip strip around this this
entire region of of uniqueness in which
there's no fish of zeroes either like
this and which is no Fisher zeros so the
picture of Fisher zeros is gradually
being being put together but it's a long
way from being resolved this this
actually gives you another algorithms
you a polynomial interpolation algorithm
analogous to the veidt's one for the
ferromagnetic easing model and then
determine anyone in the when you have
decay of correlations this is relating
decay of correlations to to polynomial
interpolation if you like hmm so when
you have decay of correlations
polynomial interpolation also works in
this particular example and there's a
lot of beautiful work which I hope
sometime in the semester we'll hear more
about on mapping zeroes for example the
independence polynomial at the
independent set polynomial in which you
know similar kind of methods have been
used
and the picture is also emerging rapidly
there okay so so so similar right so
savvy so also okay and then let me also
suggest that you know so we have these
these these methods Markov chain Monte
Carlo we have we have correlation decay
and we have interpolation I'm not
suggesting these are the only ma'am you
know very recent work of NEMA and
Cheyenne using high dimensional
expansion isn't another approach is
landed okay so so it's a lot lot there
are other methods and up claiming these
but these are these are three very
widely applicable methods that tend to
tend to have nice interpretations and
physically statistical physical models
and the question is you know what kind
of relationships can we establish
between them we already know quite a bit
as I mentioned before fairly tight
connection here when graphs are amenable
and this much newer method you know I've
attempted today to briefly mention very
tenuous connections between it and
correlation decay via results like this
and even more tenuous connections
between this and Markov chain Monte
Carlo via that stuff about like a lot of
concavity of the coefficients so so you
know there's these these connections
here are pretty pretty wide open in
general or even in specific cases and
finally let me mention you know so there
so I've talked a lot about the using
model another problem where it's
somewhat similar situation in a sense is
that is the permanent or perfect
matchings okay so so this is the top
coefficient of the matching polynomial
and there's all kinds of other important
applications so this is here we have a
situation where a lot is known so we we
have randomized and deterministic
algorithms for computing the whole
polynomial the whole matching polynomial
so without the without the perfect in
there so evaluating that polynomial
well actually randomized is better in
the sense that it doesn't require the
degree to be bounded for example yeah
yeah it's sort of a similar situation to
the easy model so we have a we have a
Markov chain Monte Carlo algorithm for
for matchings and indeed for the
permanent right so for the yeah we have
a good randomized approximation
algorithm of any matrix firm and any
matrix with with positive entries with
non-negative entries once again you
listed this is what we have to beat but
we imagine that it can probably be d
randomized and we know a lot already
about the structure of the matching
polynomial oh yeah so as I say we have
we have deterministic algorithms for for
bounded degree
matching matching pool no no not not the
permanent but matching polynomial and so
what can we do about what can we do
about the permanent deterministically so
you know you'll hear a lot to have heard
quite a bit already